FBI INVESTIGATORS ARE
SEARCHING THE HOME OF THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE.
THAT'S IN CARMEL, INDIANA.
WE'RE TOLD ONE OF PENCE'S
PRIVATE LAWYERS IS THERE AS THEY
SEARCH THE PENCE HOUSE.
LAWYERS HAVE BEEN GOING BACK AND
FORTH WITH THE GOVERNMENT ON
JUST WHEN AND JUST HOW IT WOULD
HAPPEN.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE AND SOME OTHER
BIG LEGAL DEVELOPMENTS WITH MIKE
PENCE.
WITH ME TO SHARE REPORTING AND
INSIGHTS, EVAN PEREZ, FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR ELLIOTT
WILLIAMS, AND PAULA REID.
THIS WAS NEGOTIATED.
THIS IS NOT A WARRANT AT THE
PENCE HOUSE.
BUT STILL THE FBI WANTS TO GO
IN, THE VICE PRESIDENT, THEY
FOUND CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
THERE.
THEY WANT TO GO THROUGH THE
HOUSE TO SEE IF ANYTHING ELSE.
>> TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYTHING
ELSE.
YOU KNOW, IN THE CASE OF THE
VICE PRESIDENT -- FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT, HE AND HIS LEGAL TEAM
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO BEND OVER
BACKWARDS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FBI CAN COME IN, DO THIS SEARCH,
AND HOPEFULLY FIND NOTHING ELSE.
AND THEN PERHAPS HE CAN THEN
MOVE ON TO HIS POLITICAL DUTIES
THAT HE WANTS -- YOU KNOW, HE
HAS PLANS TO GO TO IOWA AND SO
ON.
SO THIS IS THE BEST WAY FOR HIM
TO GET THIS OVER WITH AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
YOU WILL NOTE RIGHT NOW THIS IS
STILL BEING HANDLED BY THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
IT'S BEING HANDLED BY THE FBI,
NOT BY A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO AVOID THAT.
WE ALSO EXPECT THAT IN THE NEXT
FEW DAYS WE'RE GOING TO SEE
ANOTHER SURGE OF PENCE'S THINK
TANK OFFICE, A PRIVATE OFFICE
ACROSS THE STREET FROM THE FBI
BUILDING IN DOWNTOWN WASHINGTON.
AGAIN, IF EVERYTHING GOES AS
THEY HOPE IT DOES, THEN THIS
SHOULD BE WRAPPED UP, THEY
BELIEVE, VERY, VERY SOON, AND
THEY CAN MOVE ON WITH MIKE
PENCE'S POLITICAL PLANS.
>> RIGHT.
BUT YOU'RE LOOKING TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY DOCUMENTS.
WE SHOULD BE CLEAR, WHEN
DOCUMENTS WERE FOUND AT
MAR-A-LAGO AND THEN WHEN THE
PRESIDENT, JOE BIDEN, FOUND
DOCUMENTS FOUND IN HIS OFFICE,
MIKE PENCE SAID I DON'T HAVE
ANY, I DIDN'T TAKE IN, I
WOULDN'T DO THAT.
IT TURNS OUT HE DID HAVE SOME.
SO THE QUESTION IS, NUMBER ONE,
YOU WANT TO CHECK THE HOME, THE
OFFICE, YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
THERE ARE NO MORE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS IN PLACES THEY DO NOT
BELONG.
THEN THEY ALSO HAVE TO DO THE
WORK OF HOW DID THEY GET THERE.
INTERVIEWS WITH HOW DID THEY GET
THERE, WAS IT JUST INADVERTENT,
WAS THERE ANY NEFARIOUS INTENT.
>> EXACTLY.
THEY ARE CONDUCTING A REVIEW,
INITIALLY WHAT THEY DID IN THE
BIDEN CASE.
TO LOOK AT HOW DID THIS HAPPEN
EXACTLY, WAS THIS IN
INADVERTENT, WAS THIS PART OF
THE CHAOS OF THE FINAL DAYS OF
AN ADMINISTRATION, ARE THERE
TRUE QUESTIONS OF CRIMINALITY
HERE.
THE BEST CASE IS THEY FIND NO
MORE DOCUMENTS AT THE HOME OR
OFFICE.
IF THAT'S THE CASE, IT IS LIKELY
THERE PROBABLY WON'T BE A
FULL-BLOWN CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION HERE.
IT'S NOT JUSTICE WHAT GOES ON AT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IT'S
AUTOPSY THE COURT OF PUBLIC
OPINION.
HE'S TRYING TO DRAW A CONTRAST
WITH FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP, OF
COURSE, BY BEING INCREDIBLY
COOPERATIVE WITH THE FBI BUT
ALSO IN MOVING QUICKLY.
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS THAT IT TOOK
WEEKS AND WEEKS TO CONDUCT THEIR
SEARCHES IN OTHER RESIDENCES,
THEY WEREN'T ALWAYS TRANSPARENT
WITH THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
THAT IN ADDITION TO BEING THE
PRESIDENT IS HOW HE GOT A.
DEFINITELY LEARNING FROM OTHER
PEOPLE'S MISTAKES HERE.
AS I'VE NOTED, TRYING TO MOVE
THIS ALONG AS FAST AS POSSIBLE
SO HE CAN POTENTIALLY MOVE
FORWARD WITH A CAMPAIGN.
>> SO IF THERE IS JUST SLOPPY --
IF THIS IS JUST SLOPPY,
INEXCUSABLE, BUT IF IT'S JUST
SLOPPY, IT'S DONE WHEN?
>> TO PICK UP ON PAULA'S POINT,
THIS IS PRACTICAL, NOT LEGAL.
UPON MIKE PENCE HAD THE BENEFIT
OF MONTHS OF MISHANDLING IN BOTH
WAYS, FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
LOOK, THESE ARE VERY DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES, AND I DO NOT MEAN
TO EQUATE THE TWO.
THE SIMPLE FACT IS HE SAW A
ROADMAP FOR HOW TO BEHAVE.
THE WAY HE BEHAVED IS YOU LET
THEM COMPLY WITH EVERYTHING.
MOST INSTANCES OF DOCUMENTS
GETTING -- ENDING UP IN THE
WRONG PLACE ARE INADVERTENT, AND
IT'S NOT A CRIME.
IF THEIR EVIDENCE DOES EMERGE
THAT IT IS OF COURSE HE OR
ANYONE AROUND HIM OUGHT TO BE
AND CAN BE PROSECUTED.
WE DON'T SEE THAT NOW.
>> LET'S MOVE, LET'S LET THE
SEARCH PLAY OUT AND SEE WHAT
HAPPENS THE NEXT FEW DAYS.
WE'LL COVER THE RESULTS OF THE
SEARCH.
LET'S MOVE ON TO WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS A MUCH BIGGER ISSUE FOR
THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT.
THE SPECIAL FROM THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL, JACK SMITH,
INVESTIGATING DONALD TRUMP.
INVESTIGATING EFFORTS TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION,
INVESTIGATING WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6th, INVESTIGATING
WHETHER THERE WAS A DELIBERATE
ATTEMPT TO DISRUPT A GOVERNMENT
PROCEEDING, TO DEFRAUD THE
UNITED STATES, IF YOU WILL.
HE WANTS THE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT TO COME INTO A GRAND
JURY AND TO GIVE TESTIMONY AND
TO TURN OVER DOCUMENTS.
WILL THE SPECIAL COUNSEL EVER
GET THAT TESTIMONY, OR WILL THIS
BE AN EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE ISSUE?
>> HE'S NOT GOING TO GET WHAT HE
WANTS.
MIKE PENCE IS THREE OPTIONS,
COMPLY IN FULL, FIGHT IT IN
COURT, OR BLOW THE WHOLE THING
OFF.
HE'S NOT GOING TO BLOW THE THING
WHAT ENDS UP HAPPENING IS THIS
GETS TIED UP IN LITIGATION.
FAIRLY SOME CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE PRESIDENT ARE GOING TO BE
PROTECTED BY PRIVILEGE.
HE CAN ASSERT IT.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT POSSIBLY
CAN.
NOW THE QUESTION IS WHAT ARE THE
GRAY AREA CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
IT'S NOT A PROTECTED
CONVERSATION, MAYBE EVEN
DISCUSSING UNLAWFUL CONDUCT AND
WHERE CAN HE BE FORCED TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
COURTS CAN FIGURE THAT OUT.
YOU AND I CAN'T.
>> HE MADE IT YEARS BY WRITE
BEING THIS IN HIS MEMOIR, RIGHT.
HE REALLY OPENED THE DOOR.
YOU CAN'T IF BEFORE A GRAND JURY
AND SAY I'M SORRY, IT A'S
PRIVILEGED.
BUT YOU CAN RELATED IT IN THE
BOOK.
>> AND THE NEED MEDIA.
HE'S GIVEN INTERVIEWS
REPEATEDLY.
>> LET ME READ FROM THE BOOK,
"IF IT GIVES YOU THE POWER,
TR
TRUMP" ASKED WHY WOULD YOU
OPPOSE IT?
I TOLD HEM I DIDN'T BELIEVE I
POSSESSED THAT UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS ARE GOING
TO HATE YOUR GUTS, PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO THINK YOU'RE STUPID."
THE QUESTION IS THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL AND HIS TEAM UNDERSTAND
THE PRIVILEGE ISSUES HERE.
SO WHAT DO THEY WANT FROM MIKE
PENCE IN THE SENSE THAT MAYBE
THEY DON'T WANT TO ASK HIM WHAT
SALT LAKE DID THE PRESIDENT SAY
TO YOU AT LEAST BEYOND WHAT'S IN
YOUR BOOK, RIGHT?
YOU WROTE -- MR. VICE PRESIDENT,
IS WHAT'S IN YOUR BOOK TRUTHFUL?
YOU'RE DONE THERE.
WERE YOU IN THE ROOM CERTAIN
TIMES, DID YOU HEAR THE
PRESIDENT?
WAS THE PRESIDENT EVER TOLD,
SIR, IF WE DO THAT IT'S ILLEGAL,
IS THAT WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR?
>> YEAH, YOU HAVE AGGRESSIVE
PEOPLE AT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
WHO ARE GOING TO USE THIS LITTLE
CRACK IN THE DOOR AND THEY'RE
GOING TO TRY TO GO A LOT MORE
FURTHER INTO THE ROOM HERE.
THEY WANT TO GET INTO THAT ROOM,
THEY WANT TO GO INTO THE OVAL
OFFICE FOR THE CONVERSATIONS IN
DECEMBER WHERE TRUMP FIRST
RAISES THE ISSUE OF CHALLENGING
THE ELECTION.
MIKE PENCE TALKS ABOUT THAT IN
THE BOOK.
HE TALKS ABOUT THOSE KEY
MEETINGS AT THE OVAL OFFICE IN
EARLY JANUARY WHERE JOHN
EASTMAN, THE LAWYER WHO CAME UP
WITH THIS IDEA OF PENCE JUST
THROWING OUT THE ELECTION
RESULTS AND, YOU KNOW,
ESSENTIALLY IMPEDING THE
TRANSFER OF POWER, THOSE KEY
MEETINGS ARE THINGS THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WANTS A LOT
MORE DETAIL OF.
NOW, THE -- YOU KNOW, I THINK
THE FIRST THING YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE IS MIKE PENCE IS GOING TO
COMPLY WITH THE SUBPOENA.
HE'S BEEN NEGOTIATING FOR
MONTHS.
AND THEY HAVE AT LEAST A FIRST
PASS WHERE THEY TALK ABOUT THE
THINGS THAT ARE IN THE BOOK
ALREADY.
AND THEN THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
CAN LOOK AND SAY, WELL, WE WANT
MORE THAN THAT.
AND YOU'VE ALREADY KIND OF
OPENED THE DOOR, AND THAT'S
WHERE DONALD TRUMP AND HIS LEGAL
TEAM HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME IN AND FIGHT -- AND I THINK
CERTAINLY THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
AND PENCE'S TEAM BELIEVE THAT
DONALD TRUMP WILL DO THAT
EVENTUALLY AND TAKE IT ALL THE
WAY TO THE SUPREME COURT.
>> SO PUT THIS INTO CONTEXT,
ELLIOTT.
YOU HAVE THIS SPECIAL COUNSEL
DEMANDING TESTIMONY AND
DOCUMENTS THROUGH THE POWER OF A
SUBPOENA, THAT'S A BRIG DEAL, TO
THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
ALSO A SUBPOENA TO THE FORMER
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER OF THE
UNITED STATES.
TWO PEOPLE WHO ESSENTIALLY HAVE
OVAL OFFICE ACCESS, WHO ARE IN
THE WEST WING, WHO ARE SUBJECT
TO MANY CONVERSATIONS WITH
DONALD TRUMP AND WITH ALL THE
PEOPLE TRYING TO HELP DONALD
TRUMP OR STOP DONALD TRUMP FROM
TRYING TO STEAL THE ELECTION.
WHAT DOES IT TELL YOU THAT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL IS TAKING THAT
STEP?
IT SEEMS TO ME IT'S LIKE A
LAWRENCE WALSH, THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR BACK IN THE
IRAN-CONTRA DAYS OR WATERGATE
DAYS, TO GO AFTER THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT AND THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER, YOU'RE WAY UP
HERE.
>> YOU'RE RATCHETING THINGS UP
SIGNIFICANTLY.
MANY INTERACTIONS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN BE SIMPLE
CONVERSATIONS, SUBPOENAS ARE
INHERENTLY MORE ADVERSARIAL AND
COME WITH THE RISK OF GOING TO
JAIL IF YOU DON'T COMPLY.
SO IT IS AN INCREDIBLY BIG DEAL.
I THINK WE SEE THESE BIG DEALS
ALL THE TIME NOW IN THIS WORLD.
ALMOST DESENSITIZED TO IT.
THIS IS PROFOUND.
>> IT IS.
IT COMPLETELY CONTRADICTS WHAT
YOU'LL HEAR FROM THE PRESIDENT'S
LEGAL TEAM NOW WHICH IS, LOOK,
THIS IS WRAPPING UP, NOTHING'S
GOING TO COME OF IT.
CLEARLY THIS IS AN ACTIVE ANDYON
GOING INVESTIGATION, THOUGH IT
APPEARS BASED ON THE PROFILES OF
SUBPOENAS THE PEOPLE THAT
THEY'RE TARGETING, THIS COULD BE
MAYBE IN THE FINAL STAGE.
THIS IS A VERY ACTIVE, ONGOING
INVESTIGATION DESPITE WHAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS MAY
WISH OR HOPE.
>> AND SO IF YOU'RE MIKE PENCE,
IF YOU'RE MIKE PENCE, HIGHWAY
TOLD BOB COSTA OF CBS NEWS THE
TRUTH IS I THINK WE'VE GOT TIME,
PEOPLE AROUND AMERICA KNOW THE
PENCES, WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY.
HE THINKS HE HAS A COUPLE MORE
MONTHS THAN NIKKI HALEY OR
SOMEBODY WHO MIGHT BE LESS KNOWN
NATIONALLY TO GET INTO THE RACE
FOR PRESIDENT.
SHE GETS IN NEXT WEEK.
TRUMP'S ALREADY IN.
OTHERS ARE THINKING ABOUT IT.
IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT CLEAR UP
THE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENT QUESTION
AND THEN THE TRUMP
INVESTIGATIONS TO WHICH PENCE IS
NOW, AT LEAST THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL WANTS HIM AS A WITNESS,
HOW LONG?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
I MEAN, I THINK THE CLOCK IS
TICKING FOR THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
IF THEY'RE GOING TO DO THIS, AND
IF YOU'RE GOING TO BRING CHARGES
AGAINST ANYONE IN A POLITICALLY
CHARGED CASE, YOU GOT TO START
DOING SOMETHING SOON.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A TRIAL
GOING INTO NEXT YEAR, YOU KNOW
-- SO THERE IS A CLOCK TICKING.
AND BY THE WAY, NOT ONLY MIKE
PENCE BUT YOU ALSO HAVE MARK
MEADOWS OUT THERE, THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY HERE THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WANTS TO TRY
TO MAKE SURE -- START THIS
PROCESS BECAUSE THEY KNOW THERE
COULD BE LITIGATION AND THAT
COULD BE PART OF THE PROCESS
HERE.
>> CLOSE IT THIS WAY, IS THIS A
COMMON SENSE, COMMON DECENCY
CLOCK, OR IS THERE A CALENDAR AT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT THAT SAYS
THIS IS AN ACTIVE CAMPAIGN, YOU
HAVE TO MAKE THESE DECISIONS BY
THIS DATES?
>> AN EXCELLENT QUESTION.
THE NICE THING ABOUT A SPECIAL
COUNSEL IS IT TRANSCENDS AND CAN
LAST INDEFINITELY IF THAT'S THE
CASE.
WE LIVE IN THE REAL WORLD.
THERE'S A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
COMING UP.
EVERYTHING IS DIFFERENT IN
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
I THINK THEY KNOW THEY'VE GOT TO
GET IT DONE BY THEN.
>> WHICH ADDS URGENCY TO THE
QUESTIONS DOES PENCE FIGHT THE
SUBPOENA, A LOT TO COME IN THE
DAYS AHEAD.